he's a finalist for the Pro Football
Hall of Fame back here in the Rich Eisen
show good to see you sir how are you
good to be here now it's the usual hand
wringing over the Pro Bowl that we see
ratings are usually through the roof sir
that's the only reason there's a game
right I know that and and that was
pretty amazing watching Mike Evans pick
off a pass and then flip it to say
quality voted as defensive players are
often decision I know that now that's
the hope I can only wonder what Pat
Shermer let me go Mehra and and Tish
were thinking as say Kwan Barclays
running her all around a wet field in
Orlando imagine being on defense I know
well now he that was he running around
back there but him and Kamara and
Elliott are rushing the passer as
defensive ends now because again this is
the this is the issue for the Pro Bowl
unlike the all-star games in the other
sports
you cannot stop a season in the NFL to
play an all-star game you just can't do
that so when do you do it
it used to be after the Super Bowl until
Roger Goodell changed it to the week
before the Super Bowl because he thought
and I think it's correct Tony he thought
it was ridiculous that the biggest
moment of the season the Super Bowl
confetti 'he's down oh wait there's one
more game like it should be game over
confetti trophy handed out will see in
september and so what what what do you
think should be done with the Pro Bowl
well one I understand Superboy is the
crowning crown jewel should be the last
game the problem with it is you have a
number of really good players that made
the Pro Bowl they're playing in this
game on Sunday right it's not literally
the best of the best because some of the
best are playing this weekend after that
I think the bigger issue rich is the
fact that it's not a football game III
bet you there was a only handful again
times out of 100 plays that guys
actually got tackled to the ground I
mean it's to an touch flag football
without the flags and it's it almost
becomes a little bit of a mockery now I
say all that it bothers me but the
reality is the majority of people
watching it enjoy it the fans enjoy you
could hear them getting excited the
ratings are there so as long as there's
ratings and everything
I don't see it going anywhere but if I
was a GM head coach and I saw my star
player playing a position that was not
his I'd have been very nervous and if I
was an offensive lineman and one of
those running backs lined up outside of
me to try to embarrass me on TV I would
have been going full-speed officer now I
had Barkley gotten hurt I were to think
you know that the coach of the Dallas
Cowboys putting him out there on defense
would have been rising to a little bit
more of a substantive conversation than
say officials are from Southern
California and that's what we threw the
call in the NFC champions we've had in a
long time about where the officials are
from number one right number two all
Jason Garrett would have have to say is
his defenses oh I did with my star
running back as well so I'm just dumb
with your story I start running back as
well I was done with everybody everyone
I had no sense and did not care about
the future of their group Toni Boselli
here on the Rich Eisen show so I will
give you the first XO type breakdown on
Super Bowl 53 of my show week what do
you think about this game on Sunday Tony
I think Brady and Belichick the
experience all that they've seen they've
done I I'm a hard time picking against
them I said that last year as well and
the Eagles found a way and so I think
the ramps give up a lot of points they
have all year until they figure out a
way to play defense against the Saints
and so I think but I still don't think
either defense is going to give up I
think there's me a lot of points scored
I think it's in the 30s both teams I
just think in the fourth quarter if
Brady has the ball that he's in win the
football game an amazing
he is remarkable what they've done
throughout their career together I don't
think we'll ever see again
they'll have a great game plan they'll
they'll have you know Belichick is the
master on defense of taking away one
thing that the Rams really want to do
maybe it's curly it'll be interesting
what they choose but at the same time I
think Shaun McVeigh he's gonna give
Belichick something that that has not
been put on tape yet so I think the
strategy the chess match back and forth
will be amazing but I still go to Brady
you were at the AFC champion thing I was
so what happened in that game that he
did Ford lined up
science I mean that I mean if you if you
want to break down this match up with a
correct call by the officials what's
correct and a no correct call by the
officials in the ran okay and a football
player lining up on sides and you have
the Chiefs and the Saints here I mean
that's how I mean that's how close
against were and again we are assuming
that will Lutz would have made that
field goal he wouldn't have Aaron he
wouldn't have parking it wound up on the
Today Show you know okay that there
wouldn't have been a Romo you're right
whereas D Ford legitimately by lining up
in the neutral zone wiped out the game
the sterling interception not not to rub
it in but rich with that said they never
say couldn't stop New England I mean 94
plays on offense for Tom Brady the three
third down pickups one of ten yards 10
yards 20 yards Edelman Edelman and Gronk
right I mean you think you have them
they couldn't touch him all day the game
plan by Josh McDaniels is outstanding
took T forward and Justin Houston out of
the football game um what did they do to
mahomes that you think McVeigh and
obviously even Wade Phillips knowing
what can come defensively what do you
think they are gonna cook up for golf
that he might not have seen before that
you know his game could be susceptible
to on that front what they did against
mahomes as they doubled they doubled
Tyree killed they said we're going to
double him with our third corner and
safety so who's that here cooks or or
woods well I think it's I think you take
cooks you tried to take cooks out of the
game what they did they took JC Jackson
the second corner and put him on the
tight end and put their number one
receiver I mean it could Gilmore the
number two receiver so what Belichick
will do he'll figure out a way and my
guess is he puts Gilmore on woods and
says that Gilmore will take woods out of
the game and if he has to double cooks
and then force golf to go to the third
receiver or it's girly stunt like let's
see the girly from the first 13 weeks of
the season
let's and he's the difference maker well
your mother by the way which would be
remarkable that just right up the road a
little I know so I mean his ticket
requests must be absurd he met
I mean how about the best runningback
arguably in football this year was taken
out of the NFC Championship game because
of performance basically I mean CJ
Anderson who was on three different
teams this year getting cut I mean he's
out there and thought girl he's on the
sidelines when when Gurley goes that
podium tonight podium for for those who
were scoring at home he's gonna get I
mean 50 60 straight minutes of are you
hurt questions he hopefully he's gonna
be ready for all that ask the question
of Tony Boselli before we send him on
down the road Chris yeah Tony poll
question today what's your favorite
Super Bowl storyline 2001 rematch
Shawn McVeigh verse Bill Belichick Tom
Brady verse time what's wrong with Todd
Gurley are the right teams here I think
it's it's either Belichick McVeigh or
Tom Brady and against time and I'll go
Tom Brady first time because one's a 41
year old football players aren't
supposed to do what he's doing certainly
after they make it as a 40 year old two
years in a row as a 42 41 year old will
we ever see anybody over 40 do that fact
is you're aligned on him doing at a 42
because it's probably pretty good if
it's out there I turned to my on an NFL
employee whenever there's gambling talk
I turn into fair enough on frozen
caveman lawyer I do not understand your
terms what do you mean by this over in
this under I don't I don't compute what
is the wine mean I don't even know
although I did hear you say that both
are in the 30 teams are gonna be in the
30s in Brockman was taking copious notes
at that very moment that's my guess
questions brought to you by our friends
at Welch's grape juice over 400 crushed
decimated and pulverized grapes crammed
into each bottle of Welch's grape juice
which pretty much leaves no room for
anything else no added sugars no added
flavors and definitely no mercy the
world's toughest antioxidants Welch's
tough as grapes I hope you could hear
your name man I am the one who gets to
do it for at the NFL hours I hope I'm up
there with you the last two years I've
been in the stands watching you right
right those five guys going up there but
we'll see
I am unbesmirched ball I'm a
professional but if there is a Sharpie
you want me to like scroll in a name
when I've got the number in the room and
maybe start lobbying you know I'm I am
for sale
you don't gamble right price you don't
gamble but you are for sale I do hope
you thank you I'd be honored to be the
one to say it I really would you're a
good man you're good you're blowing up
as a broadcaster as well Congrats on
thank you very much that's a round of
applause for Tony facilitators the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience